what's going on guys uh just before we
get into the
long awaited episode 100 uh just a quick
one just wanted to
let you guys know that we are aware
episode 99 had a few audio issues
and unfortunately episode 100 has a few
audio issues as well
as you can tell that's all been resolved
but uh just bear with us
the episode is sick it's probably
my top five one of it's in my top five
um
so yeah sit back enjoy uh grab those sip
sips
and um yeah man let's bang it out let's
go okay
i'm gonna need to find a new co-host
immediately immediately because you're
done
you're done in this space yeah yeah yeah
yeah i am i can't vouch for you anymore
bro
[Music]
[Applause]
how can i start this off
how could i start this off right how can
i start this
episode off right to really truly
encapsulate
what this episode means for one i never
thought we'd get here
okay even though you know what i mean
when i say yeah yeah yeah
yeah i'm happy we got here i'm happy we
got here um i'm ecstatic that we got it
doesn't make any sense
a hundred bro whatever 100 episodes
whenever i think about that in terms of
like digesting what that actually means
i always think
imagine trying cat to count to 100 just
like
one one two two three and
see how long that tastes exhausting
you'll be there for
ages exhausting yeah and we've got a
whole episode for every single one of
them
nah and that's not even including
patreon not including patreon
i'm surprised we're still boys i'm not
gonna lie to you
i was talking that's talking we have
spoken
we have spoken we have spoken
um so yeah man it's crazy
it is crazy and uh guys we're so
grateful
thank you so much for rocking with us
for
keeping us motivated for sending us
stuff for making us laugh for us making
you laugh
so much you know there's so much we need
to be thankful thank you to all the guys
that sent
us a couple things here yeah thank you
for the president's the presents
the [ __ ] motivation thank you for
i don't know man thank you for keeping
us afloat thank you for
helping us pat in the studio thank you
for helping us
help helping us achieve our dreams
long story short thank you for helping
us achieve our dreams and for that
we're going to take a shot gang it's a
sip sip day by popular demand
it's a [ __ ] zip zip day quite popular
let's go
let's go i hope you've got one at home
to you guys
yeah get your sip tips out gang love you
love bro
oh smooth bro the pineapple never
stops surprising me when that tequila's
in my mouth
i'm scared and you think i have to
swallow it now here we go i have a sword
you finish it off with that pineapple
and you're just like ah
thank god so guys do us a favor
please get some [ __ ] sip tips
together yeah
send us videos of the sip tips bro yeah
pictures and videos of the sip tips
let us know you're getting down with
your sip sips bro celebrate with us
okay we're 100 you man have stuck
through
all of this [ __ ] all this [ __ ] the ups
the downs
the shitty [ __ ] videos that we put up
the ones that have messed up the
the ones before the studio
the flipping echoey living room the
flipping
episodes with no video because it cut
out the episode with
weird glitchy video bits because it was
not too long ago yeah corrupted data
files
humana stuck through all of it right so
thank you so much so much thank you so
much guys it means the world
to me most of what to james and more you
know it's um it's a dream come true
net like james said at the beginning
never thought we'd get here episode 100
that's a lot of [ __ ]
episodes bro yeah so lots of episodes
100
episodes and we're not even two years in
that's flying by that's flown by flying
by
that it's flowing by 100 bro
a hundred i'm keeping everything 100
three figures of episodes bro
not clips not [ __ ] whatever's
episodes full
blown edited feature length episodes
100 of them 100 one hour episodes that's
a lot of content for you guys so
thank you man thank you thank you thank
you thank you in abundance it's
indeed it goes without saying but
obviously i'm going to say it anyway
like
thank you i can't say enough i honestly
can't say enough man without you guys we
honestly won't be here
literally we literally wouldn't be here
we wouldn't be here we're we're very
very very
very grateful yeah make sure you guys do
take a shot for us
with us as well yeah man take a shot
with us um i feel like um
the rock you know what he's doing the
terminal shout outs and stuff
he's like it's terrible tuesday
i just want to take a
take a shot for uh all of you lovely
people out there suffering and
yeah man um i'm here for it
so it's terramanta tuesdays guys take a
sip sip for us
and uh bro when we're big big maybe we
can release our own tequila and
pineapple juice
can you imagine how sick would that be
can
you imagine when we're rich rich we
start we
we make the tequila map for the sip tips
and we make our own pineapple juice too
the fresh freshly squeezed freshly
squeezed pineapple
tropicana won't be able to touch it them
sip sips are gonna
bang damn sip sips are gonna bang
absolutely
pop terramanna can chill bro and we'll
have our own
monster will be vegetables to [ __ ] off
as well i'll make my own energy drink
zoeva could do one as well oh my days
although i do want to try that so well
i've seen it i've never tried it that's
you've seen it in shop no no no i've
like i've seen that's the rocks one
though yeah yeah i've never tried it
it's one of them ones that just said
it's so
marketable yeah that i have no interest
in trying the rox energy drink
but you just see the way he markets it
and he's got his fridge in his gym and
it's all laid out there and you're like
a [ __ ] i bet that tastes bang bang
yeah but it probably does it probably
does bro because everyone's raving about
the term when
the first drop turned on everyone's
reading it bro i know speaking of energy
drinks bro
i'm not gonna lie to you monster might
be on its way out
this rain ting that you've seen me drink
before the black can you might see yes
yes they've got a flavor called peach
fizz yeah
bro pause before you continue i thought
you were gonna say you might have to go
because it's having an effect on you
oh no or did i know now no no no no no
no no no
my heart is all over the calf it doesn't
matter anymore oh wow this peach fizz
bangs rain is the new one up okay um
although someone dealing was like
man to man like reyna monster is owned
by the same that reign is owned by a
monster so always don't get too gas but
i might
give a [ __ ] okay rain is raining the
monsters monster bro they got their
flavors
true and monster bringing out that peach
fizz
they bringing out that peach fish bro it
bangs i'm gonna i know you don't like it
because it makes you [ __ ]
but i'm gonna have to give you it's
delectable bro i don't know about that
bro
i don't know about that bro all right
energy drinks don't do well for me me
and caffeine
bro it's worth the doo-doo it's actually
worth it though
i'm not going to say that it's worth the
doo-doo man it's worth the energy gives
you
the good vibes it gives me mm-hmm worth
the shits
all right say no it's worth the [ __ ] um
but guys
obviously it is a great episode but it's
always
a normal episode so we have to do our
have to do's
so guys do it for us this time
episode 100. if you're new here and you
don't
subscribe just yet just float your
finger on by that
subscribe button and just give it a
little and then whilst you're there's a
little bell next to it just get like
billing
um and then right about now you should
see
uh a thing pop up on your screen that
says patreon.com
forward slash shits and gigs just
find your way over there just type that
in the url bro and just whiz on down
to that patreon yeah and for what you
will find there
is the secret gauntlet of episodes the
[ __ ]
that they don't let on youtube the
secret sauce
roll tell them the the chalice
of unfiltered unapologetic
uncensored raw raw content
only a payable a small payroll
can hold it back you've got the devices
to
unblock that bro that's all you that's
all you bro
you can crack through that with 10p a
day
three pound a month run the p
bro run the b run the p and run straight
through that paywall
and enjoy that delicious content bro
content after content after content
after we've got a community over there
we've got communion over there and all
you men that send in the
almighty [ __ ] and the would you
rathers and the fun facts and stuff like
that and then
we found requests and we get all these
messages like yeah i'm sorry but i
messaged ages ago you still haven't said
it
that's because the patrons message first
bro
and they count more because they were
willing to dig into their pockets
or their mom's pockets or their
brother's pockets and say you know what
bro these might need it do you need it
they need to start their own tequila
company
and they can't do that off the road back
they need to pee
they need the support they need the
funding and i need these juicy juicy
episodes
bro so they bust through that paintball
so when they message us
and say hey guys what do you think about
am i the [ __ ]
we look at that and we see the email
come through
right back bro right back because that's
what they deserve
um but obviously guys you guys deserve
that too
so again thank you very much we made it
to 100.
and uh it's only up from here it is
literally
literally only from here yeah man and uh
it's good [ __ ] you also may notice the
silver number one oh yeah
the strife i had with these balloons
you men don't understand but we're here
now so we have addressed it
you guys can ignore it now yes it's a
silver one everything else is gold
couldn't care less we crack on we move
yeah
we move guys i hope you've taken your
tequila shot because we're about to go
full fledged into this episode
yeah man all right uh it's fun fact we
have a fun fact of the day guys and
today's fun fact
is in 2007 a couple called
laurie and chris cobble suffered a
tragic loss of all three of their young
children in a road accident
two girls and one boy despite their
experience
they did they decided to try again fun
for more children
six months later laurie became pregnant
and later gave birth to triplets
two girls and one boy
you know what i see
why that's a happy story but that just
makes me more sad
it's it's it i would wouldn't say it's a
happy story
no no no i knew you know i understand
that for them
yeah it's like what a tragic loss but
then what an amazing gain
yes but when i read it i think if i was
in that position
and i just lost three of my children
and then we try again and then we
literally get the exact replacements of
what we lost
i want to kill myself bro would you be
riddled with guilt yes
100 1 million percent i literally feel
like i'm replacing my kids
that's exactly how i feel that's
honestly exactly how i would focus i
would be
riddled with i wouldn't be able to look
at these kids i'll
have to leave bro i'm not lying to you
i'd have to leave i won't be able to
look at these guys
without crying you can't say that i'm
out found
out oh what do you mean i'm not i'm out
i told you i'm out
i can't
[Music]
that's um it's tough because
obviously that's not anything that i
would wish on anyone or anything but
would you not feel okay question
let's god forbid god forbid god forbid
this happened to you right
and 10 50 let's say 20 years down the
line
your um new three kids are a lot older
they understand everything and um would
you tell them what happened
in the past yeah hundred percent
100 i'll tell you how do you think
that'll make them feel
probably sad but i don't know it's just
something
i don't believe in like keeping i
wouldn't want to keep that from my kids
yeah
you know what i mean yeah i i wouldn't
want to disrespect
the kids that i lost by
trying to keep them from in the dark
yeah in the dark like trying to keep
them
from the kids that we've got yeah i mean
then i definitely would feel like
they're replacement kids
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah i would
hate to do that that makes sense
i'd hate to do that how would you feel
okay would you be against having
more kids if your wife wanted more kids
but you said no
no if your wife wanted more kids would
you say yes or no rather after this
adventure happened to you i don't know
you'd say no 100
even if she was like please please no
okay
no way really bro no way i say that
because i'm not in that position i might
you never know i might change my mind
but
it would ache bro i just don't think i
could do it
um i literally just don't think i don't
understand
how all of them can
god forbid die in a roadside accident
and
both of them survive like the parents
you know suspect
a little bit a little bit
they seemed fine i didn't see any
permanent injuries in that picture
i didn't see any permanent injuries a
little bit i'm not going to lie to you
i didn't see scars i didn't see nothing
they were smiling sketchy
they were happy with their newborns
sounds like they didn't like the first
batch that's what it sounds like to me
i'm not gonna lie i'm looking at the
picture again i'm zooming into the dad
he doesn't look happy he's not about it
look at that smile he's not a fake smile
yeah she axed off them last kids and she
said you best
slit me up the duff again otherwise
you're next
you're next actually looking at those
pictures they seem a bit west
they're consuming into them they look a
bit worse so yeah i'm saying certain
questions haven't been asked
certain questions haven't been asked or
answered
that's all i know but hey who am i to
judge
um i have a question yes
[Music]
um would you so obviously we're in this
space
now small time but we're we're in this
like
youtube podcasting and creating content
space
yes we've been here for a minute now
agreed um
how much would it take how much would
have to be on the table for you to
accept
like a youtube in boxing match these all
these fights that are against out
someone called you out youtube in boxing
if a youtuber called you out
to that feel you chat [ __ ] bro well i'm
sick or tired of your mouth bro
um let's do let's make this fight sign
the contract give me
give me like the teasing season how many
rounds are we doing so
it's going to be it's a fair fight six
rounds
six months six so let's call it six two
minute rounds six
two minute rounds but no you've got
months to prepare okay okay he's not on
the spot okay
you've got months to prepare you get to
go to like a 12-week camp everything
is a big deal bro okay and it's money on
the table
but what's like the minimum that you
take
in my current state not not necessarily
my current physical state but in our
country tomorrow
tomorrow he called you out tomorrow
without sounding
greedy or selfish i'd probably it's
gonna sound really selfish anyway
i'd probably say like 50 bucks 50 bags
no that's why is that greedy or selfish
no no
it just seems like a lot considering i'm
the one nah brodies man are making
millions of these fights
true i mean it's true um i feel like if
someone's
hollering me for a fight then they're
probably around the same caliber
yeah okay yeah yeah yeah you know
50k for this fight bear in mind like my
man
obviously this comes along with the
opportunity he could smack you up yeah i
know i know i know
like he could put you on your body i
know you know the ones where um
like he puts you on your back and you
double bounce like that on the floor
like your bongos boom boom
sounds like you're you're you're
stronger you're strong as strong as
strong you're strong and strong you're
strong
you're asking oh god and you're your
back is stunned oh god anything
you just got rocked and the whole world
sees it
50k you have to come back in here
tomorrow you have to come back in there
the next monday
battered and bruised and tell everyone
what happened like
when what they want to know like bro how
could you let man manage you like that
i mean how could you let a man put his
hands on you like that
he's really asking me that you oh i
would have to ask your ass i
have to ask him you have 12 weeks to
prepare
he put blows on you um
that's still further 150k in the up yeah
yeah yeah
um two the amount of recognition that
would give
us a loan would be insane fair enough
bro you're willing to take an ass with
me for the pod i have to rate you
i mean obviously you might not take it
out that's what i'm saying you're saying
it like
it's a guaranteed loss that's why my boy
doesn't even believe
i just need to be prepared my boy
doesn't even believe in me cuz
you know our formula to be in this we
are in this i just want you to look at
it from all angles
i know the thing is this is the lion's
den and he called you
out you don't know what he's been doing
backstage
i don't know i'd have to assess it
because i i don't know i'd have to
see what he's about see what he looks
like see if he's been hitting the gym
all these things i need to know because
it was actually you know arms collion is
doing a fight
yes yeah bounce the song yeah playboy
i don't use it what if arms called you
out after no
what are you talking about how much
we're in two completely different worlds
yeah he says
you have to run me a meal a meal to
fight arms calling
you'd have to run me a mill he's one bro
i stab him on the spot
again ring and stab him on the spot
he would kill him you would [ __ ]
destroy me
obviously he destroyed me so i'll just
write everyone guys excuse my voice i'm
so sorry he'd [ __ ] kill me
yeah of course you would you'd have to
run me it'd annihilate you bro
it'd have to be money money money money
bro and i would make the fight so quick
he'll give me one bank and i'll drop i
won't even stand up
there has to be a clause in the contract
you can't throw this fight bro
how would they know i was throwing it oh
they know they're professionals bro bro
there can't be any suspicion that you've
thrown this fight but but
look at the size difference bro if you
rocks my drawers how are they to know
that i'm not faking it or i am faking it
yeah obviously if you've rocked your job
but what i'm saying is if
if he's going to run instinctively if
he's throwing a punch you're going to be
like this
and if you take one of the elbow and
just fall over the the rebel drapes you
up
imagine i'd rock the rest get the [ __ ]
he said off ain't getting this money you
better get your [ __ ] act together
oh you are making a penny as soon as i
hear that i'm staring at you from i look
at ringside like
james what do i do fam
i'll be there just all pins and needles
you'll be mining get up get up get up
where is it um have you seen troy
i've actually not you know you've never
seen troy actually you've never seen
toronto that's a [ __ ] movie bro you
need to see it
there's a there's a scene in troy where
basically there's a war
and it's all based about one guy orlando
bloom stealing another guy's
wife wife yeah i've seen like bits of
people i've never seen the whole movie
talks all chests then he's going to
scrap his mind man okay he says louder
it's a one-on-one thing yeah that's gold
yeah fam
so he's a one-on-one my head is bouncing
off this balloon bro
it's a one-on-one thing orlando bloom is
is all about the [ __ ] he's never fought
anyone but his brother eric banner
he's about this life he's about yourself
so he warned him he said i'm gonna call
them out on a one-on-one thing
i saved all these lives it's a
one-on-one saying everybody said fam
don't do it you don't know what you're
getting into he's a seasoned vet
you ain't never done nothing you've
never killed a man i've killed bear man
it's not it's not it's the life it's for
you bro
you're a jealous
you ain't you're not about this yeah
you're trying to gum some yeah
you know what i mean you're not not
about this life yeah you're all talk
yeah
he said [ __ ] it bro so 101 fam
his shield bounced off two-two orlando
blue was shaking
shaking shaking grabbed his brother said
help
when he said and his dad is that's the
king right his dad
he's got some husky voice and he's
looking down it's like fight him
and he's crying like fight him he's so
ashamed of his son
oh my god i gotta be squealing he crawls
behind his brother's legs like
yeah so if you look at me like that i
have to say
bye fam for the love of god
get up you can never have a
ref bring you up by your shorts
like this and you look at me for help
i'll say you better
you better balls bro this is this is our
reputation on the line i would do so
many legal moves
oh you'd have to i'd have to knock him
down somehow
he would he wouldn't he'll touch you up
bro
he'll put hands on you i couldn't see my
boy get manhandled like that
i could've could i'd have to i have to
because i can't even step in and save
you
arms will have you up that said save me
like you want to get rocked too
excited i can't get in i can't do
anything that's what i'm saying like
that's when i said i can't get in their
savior i'm not saying because of the
rules of the fight
i said he'll bang me he'll bang me as
well i can't protect you
oh my god you said i'm trophies
laugh at me yeah yeah laugh at me you'll
have to be a cool meal
call me i'll call me you'll take that
that kind of beating for a meal for
cornell i'll write that
what were you to fight arms
i do it for like 200k um
happily hmm that's money i'll probably
do it for 100k
i probably have 75. i'll probably do it
for 75. i would really i
would have because i know for a fact i'm
getting brain damage off the road oh 100
so am i
but like 75k bro i don't think you
understand what my finances are actually
saying
i don't think anyone really understands
what finance is actually saying
75 bags yeah i'll fight him bro
i'll fight him i have to prop up i'll
have to fight him
moxie match i'll have to fight him i've
given him my everything
i'm giving about as soon as the bell
goes i'm dropping bombs on his nose
bombs the quick ones yeah yeah you know
where did you hear that
that's all you're hearing bro and then
back up you know
your toes just like all right now here
comes the thunder
here i know it's a wrap
i know i'm clinching i'm hugging his
waist
amanda's swinging you know my legs leave
the floor oh my
game oh my i couldn't you see the
tassels on my shorts just
shaking
what would be what would be your ring
music when you walk in
my ring music um sometimes i think i
take
comedy too far and i feel like i'll do
something stupid
but um
what would my ring music be
um probably maybe like the
you know the the intro music to pain
from naruto
was like
[Music]
pain i don't remember it's like
[Music]
and it's like an undertone of just like
it sounds like doom
when they're in um is it just before
when naruto comes back from
um from the sage land
[Music]
[Music]
well bro don't hype the crowd up yeah
yeah
yeah i'm down for the threesome
bro i'm that i'll be here for him
trembles around wembley a
bro i'm probably gonna be in a [ __ ]
derelict squad
a pup oh my days that's a lot when i
used to fight they used to put the
events in [ __ ] you know work in men's
club
yes they used to be in there it's stunk
a bit
of course and i can't breathe i'm out of
breath and all it is is
beer and smoke oh [ __ ]
that it was the drex bro
and these men have like so they have
these months to prepare stuff for that
but i used to fight every other week
i was there yeah bro i used to fight all
the time
i remember one time i was eating my
dinner and my coach rang me said if
there's
there's a fight tonight if you want it i
was eating my dinner
it's a fight tonight if you want it
man's talking as if you're swapping
chips
they treat when you're an amateur boxer
bro they treat you like it is like that
wow it's a shift bro you stay in shape
there's no preparing for this fighting
bro you stay in shape ma'am brandon when
i was eating my [ __ ] pasta
a man said yo what are you doing i said
i'm eating dinner what are you doing
i said there's a fight in huntington are
you down i said not really bro
i'm eating my dinner what are you doing
funny
i said well not really bro yeah our man
said bro
we need a fighter there's a guy waiting
for you
are you about it all right so you win
yeah you pick me up i'll be there in ten
pick me up i don't even get to visit my
dinner
no way bro pick me up and went to london
and had to fight some guy i've never met
how did how did that go
i lost i lost that fight was it was it
close was it
yeah it was like one of them um it was
like a just like out because amateur is
mainly about it's not like a knockout
team
okay i've never knocked out anyone in
any of my fights ever
um it's just not that's no no no no no
um but um yeah
it was just one of them fights to think
on my way um
just lost on points he was it was i tell
you what it was
this don had no technique okay
you ever um how do i explain it
have you ever played a sport with
someone who's so bad at that sport
that they're actually beating you
because you just don't know what
to predict it's basically like you're
playing tekken and they're opponents but
i'm bashing and they're bringing yes
all the [ __ ] scenes that's exactly
that's practicing that's the best
analogy that's the best and that's the
[ __ ] best analogy bro
it's the best analogy you're playing
someone who's never played tekken before
and they're butting my [ __ ] and they're
[ __ ] you up
because you just don't know what's going
on you don't have to be excited and
you're like big man you're frustrating
me because you're actually [ __ ] yeah and
they're like yeah but i'm smashing you
up
that's what my man was the hunted and
done he was any bread that he just
got adrenaline and started swinging
just like swinging wouldn't stop
swinging and you know this is not how
this goes
bro we take the first round we feed each
other out cover kaka
then once a couple jabs here and there
and then next round we'll get rid of
it yeah and we'll see who's the better
boxer he wasn't interested in that
swinging it until he couldn't swing
anymore no and just got to the point
where it's just like
i don't know what to do tomorrow this is
not like in my repertoire
i'm trying to get loose i'm trying to
show off some footwork
man wasn't about it you know how much
your box did you wear headgear
um fun fact the most frustrating thing
it makes it worse okay because it's like
an extra half an inch this way
and an extra half an inch oh so they can
actually so your head is bigger
yeah and heavier i've not thought about
that so when you're used to
a punch going here and moving from it
you have to be here now there you're not
slipping
and your head's weighted bro okay and
when one gives you a little
and your head goes back it takes energy
to bring it back forward
it rocks your neck embarrassing
so it's just annoying it doesn't feel
comfortable and i remember when i first
started boxing we would never was used
to
the budget for my club wasn't like a
proper proper club so we didn't really
have much of a budget
so that their equipment was limited that
they had the coaches would have to buy
the equipment themselves okay
so we didn't have headgear so we used to
just spa
no headgear just gum shield buy my bank
so when i've had fights
it was the first time i ever even tried
headgear
so i had nothing i was so it took like
five fives for me to get used to it
oh wow it was awful bro
awful i think my first five only one
like one of them
oh wow and as soon as the monster
started getting used to it your boy was
up
your boy was up and popping okay but um
it was horrible yeah i hated it um and i
got robbed in my first ever fight i lost
robbed i was uh i smashed him up mm-hmm
smashed well then the referee was right
smashed him up bro i fought out my skin
that's annoying it wasn't like there was
booze in the crowd everything
okay so even the fans used it yeah yeah
i got approached by like three old white
men like you got that dinner
yeah just drunk white guys over here
um but yeah i just lost 50 quicker to
you he's like
you won though you won because i chose
me i was like
14. wow that's young
to get into mortal kombat but the
stranger
that's young man most terrifying thing
when i said to you about when
adam sure said the other day we couldn't
fit his legs on the bed going up to that
the big walk-out thing never been so
scared of my life never been so scared
of my life
wow breaking it bro i can imagine
i literally wanted like i didn't even
know
a tsunami to hit you wasn't one sword i
wanted the world to stop just to get
this canceled yeah i want an asteroid to
come through the ceiling just to cancel
this bro
i wanted to back the [ __ ] out yeah not
one
ounce of me wanted to do this i was so
scared
but then afterwards when the adrenaline
hits even though i lost i was like i'll
do it again
put me in a room with someone else but
then when you do it as well
it's another thing as well so you see
how obviously like fighters
you um you have your changing room and
stuff like that and fighters have their
room
and there's just them and their coach
and they're ready and all this stuff
yeah so
it's different we're in the amateur you
go there
and you're in this one room with
every other box of this fight in there
really no one has their own [ __ ] oh yeah
true you're in one room with every other
boxer that's there
and to top it off you don't know who
you're fighting
um you have no idea oh [ __ ]
you have no idea are you inviting all
the names until you get in the ring
really you have no idea who you're
fighting
all you know is that you're sitting
there
waiting nervous as [ __ ] and if you're
late i remember one match i had was
really late
and then the numbers the room will just
get smaller and smaller
cats are you thinking who am i gonna
fight yeah i don't know
and then teams would obvious obviously
like leave and start warming up
in different areas so eventually it
would just be me and then
there's one that i had i remember it's
just me and my coaches one other
guy from my my team was fighting as well
so my coaches weren't even in there with
me
i was in this massive room just me and
all i could hear in the other room was
cheering and like
screaming and all this stuff i'm just
there like i'm next
i'm the only one here i have to be there
it's
terrifying bro [ __ ] never miss us yet
nervous to say you sit there i saw it
bro the officials coming horrible
a black door dead bro horrible in that
massive room echoey room
just bags and shoes and everything in
there just me and all you can hear
across the wall that's here is screaming
i would back i promise you but
and then as soon as you can hear you
hear him walking down the footsteps and
he's your coach he's like
you ready let's go
[Music]
okay let's go let's go and you think i
could come back here in 10 minutes
and have a concussion my nose could be
broken when i walk back in this room
when i come in here to get my bag i
don't know what state i'm gonna be yeah
they they could be dragging me by my
legs
i don't know where and what i'm going to
be like on the way back up once i leave
this room i don't know what state i'm
going to be when they come back
horrible [ __ ] that bro not built for it
oh
i fell into it i had no intention i
didn't want to be a boxer
i just my boys did it so i just wanted
to do it oh fair
fair i don't know you were talking about
that yeah actually to be faster my boys
did it
one of my boys did it my boy john did it
okay
and he was talking the most smack the mo
smack
i'm a box of this i'm a boxer yeah show
your [ __ ] man
i said i'll rock on there tomorrow bro
and he was like big man there's a
waiting list they wouldn't even let you
in
i said yeah yeah i remember i lived like
two miles away
because i lived so far from my school
but just moved to north
not just moved to we'd moved to north
and i got i didn't get accepted
to the school that wasn't in my
catchment whatever so i had to work two
masters of school
so i was going there and obviously
that's that school that i went to has
his own leisure center
and that's where the boxing club was and
he was like i'm a boxer there someone
boxing that's a waiting this is like a
three-month foreigners they won't let
you in
or the only reason they let me in is
because i'm like talented and all this
stuff and i said big man i'll rock up
there tomorrow and i'm probably there
let me
say yeah do it then say that
yes so i left i left my yard had my
dinner left my yard walked
all the way two [ __ ] miles bro all
the way to [ __ ] ages
got there nervous peeked in
see my boy just boxing and he was like
just
thinking you're about to get kicked out
bro yeah you don't belong here yeah i
went to speak to the head coach told him
every time i said i want to be a box
holder stuff he's alright i'll try he
gave me like a try out thing
so come back on wednesday i'll try it
out and see what one family was ready
came in ready yeah yeah yeah i had to go
into beginner's class it was me
and like two eight-year-olds and then
like this is how old were you
i was probably 13 when i started okay 14
when i had my first fight
so yeah and it was like the mean is too
little use
and one of the assistant coaches like
said this is a jab
came with like the this is what this
looks like and even proper like
boxy like this and it's like you just
twist your hand like that
and like your proper like over-exert so
like show you what you're supposed to do
yeah what's that and i'm just there with
these two little uses like
yeah i had it in my head like because
they what they used to do at the
beginning of every session they were
like
beginners here like regulars here
and boxers come with me the boxes had
their own training thing okay and they
would always take my point
and it'll always look at me like you're
not ready for this you hit a box a big
man
you're a beginner so i'll move from
beginners eventually mood into the
regulars
and then regular regular and then
um one day out of the blue same thing
beginners over here regulars here boxes
here
cool i'm ready and then one of the
coaches was like james
boxes here
elated elated
bro literally
as he said it i could see confetti yeah
and it's like i get i
get i get i get
i sh you conor mcgregor
i stride over to my back i could have
knocked my boy in his jaw right then and
there
just like you are not even ready bro man
didn't even ask for this
i fell into it so how long from the
beginners till you got that
uh from beginners to that day was
probably like
six months that's not that bad um six
months
that's really good yeah beginners to
like yeah six months
and then from there i was probably in
like the boxers category for like a
probably like another six months
and then they were like oh it's time for
your first fight shock
did you ever fight this boy your boy no
no no you would never fight someone from
the same team as you mm-hmm
never about inspiring and stuff yeah we
sparred um
we sparred all the time and he was good
he he was really good boxer
um we used to go though well i used to
not enjoy sparring him too much because
it would literally
like [ __ ] with our friendship because we
were so competitive yeah i couldn't
stand [ __ ] losing to him yeah i
couldn't stand it and he always had like
two years on me yeah no matter what if
i'm three years in he's five
yeah yeah jeremy so he'd always have
more experience with me and to the point
where i physically i broke down crying
one time
because we were sparring i couldn't beat
him couldn't beat him i was
so frustrated bro so frustrated
could not [ __ ] be him so frustrated
that i got so angry that i was ready to
rock
like take my gloves off and actually
let's just [ __ ] these rules bro
let's go let's go i was crying i have
anger oh [ __ ] angry bro
yeah not good sorry bro here's what it
is this is what it is
but then yeah we move all right i've got
a question for you yeah
so there was a day this was i think this
was last week earlier
this week i was absolutely ravenous and
i had to have i hadn't had
toast in such a [ __ ] long time yeah
and i saw her on either tick tock or on
twitter of a title video about how men
cut their sandwiches i.e
horizontally or diagonally you know i
mean triangles or rectangles exactly
yeah yeah yeah
if that's easy for you to triangles or
rectangles but i was ravenous so i got
i had like two like four slices of toys
so like two
toy sandwiches kind of thing so i cut
them i cut one of them horizontally and
i cut one
diagonally i was thinking i wonder if
there is a difference in like
the enjoyment and how are you enjoying
how you experienced this
is the toast okay so
i think i i went for the horizontal one
first ate it
didn't really because i feel like i've
always
when you buy sandwiches in shops they're
always diagonal well nine times out of
ten though it was diagonal but
sometimes if you do at home maybe a lot
of people cut them horizontally
so i ate the horizontal one first and i
hate the triangle one
second and i was thinking they were both
pretty much the same but then it came to
the choice of
which one which one do i have next which
one do you prefer to go
next yeah which ones i prefer to go for
next i was thinking
am i subconsciously gonna pick the one i
like or am i just gonna pick
and then i picks the i picked the
diagonal
and i was thinking it really doesn't
make that much of a difference but i can
understand why
it was tick-tock it was ticks because
someone was saying you've got an entry
point
because there's a corner yeah that's the
whole time you were thinking about it i
was
thinking about taking a little bite out
of that corner
taking a little bit of the corner
because you've got you've got an entry
point yeah yeah
it kind of makes sense it's easy to eat
but also when you have a sandwich that's
sometimes like i like that i'm getting
in there i like getting in there but
then you're left with two like
yeah yeah yeah wedges on the side yeah
yeah i see what you mean
so my question to you is how do you cut
your sandwich and how do you eat your
sandwich cool
so i cut my sandwich
rectangles okay um
i've never made a sandwich diagonals in
my life that's fancy fancy
neither have i until i did that but when
you're saying about the toast thing
it's interesting that you mentioned that
you were ravenous so if i'm
starving and i make toast part of the
reason i like it being horizontal
because when i said when you said about
the triangles and the entry point
i picture a little bite a little fancy
bite
like that when i do one heart if i'm
starving
i will cut it into my um horizontal
my yeah my horizontal my rectangles and
i'll fold it
okay end to end and i'm taking a massive
wipe out okay
okay and i want it in my mouth as fast
as possible
so when you said you were ravenous i was
thinking i would never cut triangles
from there
to do
if i'm starving no that's hilarious but
yeah no way
no way um but yeah that's an interest
that's such a
[ __ ] random question but it's
interesting
it is right i was so hungry and i was
like
i saw the video i think maybe the day
before and it's not something i'd ever
even consider
but because i've made toast i was
thinking let me actually try it
it [ __ ] with me i was like let me ask
you and see how it goes fair play
yeah man um let's do another sip sip and
then let's do pick your poison
so guys we've decided 100 episodes um
we'll let you in on this picky poison
game that you guys never get to see
you never get to see unless you're on
patreon you never get to eat booking
poison so we're going to do one for you
guys now
uh yeah recipe guys uh take another mid
sip sip if you guys have your shot
glasses and your tequila with you
join us
[ __ ] up gang kmg happy 100
happy 100 guys
i felt that coursing through my body oh
yeah
that's nice oh all right guys whenever
you pick your poison yes sir
um for the youtubers that aren't on
patreon
pika poison is very very similar to
would you rather
but it's a lot more extreme um so yeah
that's how we keep it from patreon but
i'm gonna do one
so cool pick your poison
either instinctively know when everyone
you know
is going to die but be unable to do
anything about
it or randomly find a dead
body in your closet oh yeah
oh wow that's got layers that has got
layers initially i
i'll let you do it
instinctively know when everyone i know
is going to die when and how or just
when
when when they're going to die you can't
do [ __ ] about it
i'm basically a shinigami yeah yeah and
basically for that for those that don't
know what
kami is it means you're a death god
um and what's the second one or find a
corpse in your closet
sticky it is sticky
um
i think off the bat
i would have to choose knowing when my
friends are gonna die
and the only reason it's not like it's
something i'm proud of choosing but the
only reason why i want to
choose that over the other one is
because i know for a fact if the police
find out i've got a dead body in my
closet
i don't know how i'm getting out of that
exactly you're not i don't know how i'm
getting out of that situation james what
do i say
what do i say to them you know
i'm done for there's no explanation
there is no explanation
especially if it was a woman oh god
forbid it's a woman
god you know what's crazy
no once would that ever cross my mind
until you just said especially if it's a
woman
if it's a woman you're [ __ ] bro a good
looking woman
oh sir
get your wrist ready you're going to pen
you're going pen penis a dead a dead
painting in your closet
big boy pen you're done for
bro i could i couldn't you're done for
you couldn't tell me to happen i know i
know i know
i know i know i couldn't bro it's
dread i'm a need to find a new co-host
immediately immediately because you're
done
you're done in this space yeah yeah yeah
yeah i am i can't vouch for you anymore
bro
yeah correct there's a painting dead in
your closet no
i'm sorry bro that's assault brother
that's assault brother i know where it
is bro
oh i'd have to be a shinigami all right
i just know what bridge is going on
simple straightforward i can't i just
couldn't
are you sure fam no i'm not sure but
you're gonna be looking at me right now
doing this show knowing i'm gonna die in
x amount of time
bro we could be talking about our here's
to another hundred you could know i
ain't making it to episode 200.
don't say that it's true i know
i mean it's not but i know but bro i
just couldn't find a dead white woman in
my closet
i just couldn't find a dead white woman
in my closet dead white woman
oh on this climate that we're in yeah
i'm going i'm not even making it to jail
don't you think it's weird you're not
making it now you said that don't you
think it's crazy how
the age and the ethnicity
of the corpse age ethnicity and gender
of the corpse
means everything everything if you found
an 87 year old indian woman in your
closet
you're scot-free i wouldn't say scott
you're not scot-free but you're like
this makes sense yeah this wasn't me it
wasn't me bro
this just wasn't me why would i attack a
random indian woman i didn't even make
any sense
you've got so much deniability so much
you got no prints on there
yeah no hair you're fine not fine
but you can get out of this yeah yeah if
i pattern a good lawyer yeah
yeah fam 26 year old
thick white thick slim thick
white thing botox in the lips
[ __ ] me eyes sorry jade
penitentiary your rape isn't a murderer
i'm not
i'm telling you i'm not making it to
jail that might not that man are killing
me before i get there
oh yeah one hundred if you make it
your first night it's gonna be a roller
coaster the homeboys
i'd have to tell myself i don't know how
i do it
have you ever seen jamie foxx's stand-up
when he's in africa
not when he's in f where he talks about
the story when he goes to africa you
have to give me more
yes that brings up
yes yes yes yes yes there's a bit where
he goes
i can imagine you and your first night
in your cell
just looking around and you can hear the
boys
new skin new skin nah come pay me a
visit boy i'll protect you
i look after you these men want you
these might want you done out here call
me i'll protect you
bring those soft little cheeks over here
come stay in my bed
nah
you can share my bed no brother
no brother it's just not happening
it's just not happening you miss home
there ain't no pink white thing in your
closet
you must pray to god bro if there's a
penguin in my closet
the thing is i i can't even say i'd
leave i'd move i burned a yard because
it makes me
more guilty oh hundred percent who do i
call
james this literally literally is the
plot of a night off
this is literally the plot of a night
off what's the night of
the thing with my man the asian don the
three-part donkey series
draw donkey drama whatever not even dog
you just drama
a night oh if you don't remember the
night of have i seen it
i hope you have you must have we i'm
sure we've spoken about a night off
um it's the guy who plays the assistant
in nightcrawler the
asian guy the assistant
you don't like caller yeah jake didn't
know and he hires the cameraman the
assistant yes
who he kills at the end yes spoiler yes
my man
is in uh uh like a three or four part
series
i have called never seen it never even
heard of it
fantastic fantastic [ __ ]
fantastic okay masterpiece
okay masterpiece bro
i've never heard of it bro check it
i won't spoil it but this is the plot
but i have to spoil it
so it's my man yeah what is his name i i
will never remember
he's british his name is uh
[ __ ] i can't remember his name that's
fine wish ahmed
rizza rizzo muhammad yes you meant his
real name if you mean his name in the
table no i don't i oh i got clue his
name is in the thing
riz ahmed okay so it's my man
he is on his way out to a party
or something like that and he bumps into
some
some white girl i think i don't know if
they can't remember if they share a taxi
or something he basically bumps into
this white girl
she's offering i can't remember if she's
a prostitute or what but she's offering
him sloppy tops
she's trying to [ __ ] she's paying
so she's like come back to yard he goes
back to yard
and lips in drinking laffy laffy laffy
i can't i think they have sex
i can't remember i can't remember if
they have sex or not
he said relevant to the story he drinks
until he passes out basically yeah
wakes up like in the middle of the night
goes to check on her goes upstairs she's
[ __ ] dead bro
stabbed to death
is this a show is real it's a show
okay it's ris ahmed he's an actor yeah i
know he's an actor fun but you when you
said docuseries i was thinking maybe
yeah i did a lighting
yeah sorry you had to scrap the document
okay it's a three-part drama
okay i say three-part could be ten parts
i don't remember but all i remember is
drama and there's parts yeah bro
yeah she's dead stabbed the [ __ ] to
death
laying on the bed obviously my man's
panicking
obviously and bro it unravels from there
basically they arrest him and if the
whole show is him going through his
trial
while he's in pen boy he adapts to pen
life bro
really adapts to pen life it's
[ __ ] amazing show bro
okay i'm going to watch it bro thank you
i'm going to watch it you catch one
brother in there
suck in big one new team one rookie
rocks up and he's got the fat stick
sucking lips
it's he's young as well bro like 18.
one guy takes him under his wing just
says suck me off
and then ris is just walking past the
cell and just peeps it one time says
and runs off and runs off
he was making man suck him off oh god no
should i protect you by our price bro
i couldn't make it you have to watch a
night off i see
like yeah bro you have like is like you
know when we say stuff like oh yeah
loki's great
like a night of [ __ ] amazing it's the
best
like it's as far as like party dramas
like like a show show kind of thing the
best thing i've ever seen
okay it's film like quality amazing bro
how long ago was it
oh i watched it like two three years ago
and did it come out two three years ago
is that when you just watched you might
have been out a year
okay i watched it i think it might be
new because i think i watched it on sky
atlantic
okay atlantic they don't [ __ ] about
bro [ __ ] about bro that's what i'm
telling
you no more don't [ __ ] about it when you
know that's game of thrones level yes
when you know sky atlantic are [ __ ]
with it bro rhys army
atlantic yeah say no more it's a
probably
okay yeah i'm here
is basically the british hbo it is they
don't play games
they do not play games
you've got me gasps oh speaking of i was
going to talk to you about black summer
you have to watch black stuff it's on
netflix for everyone that hasn't
watched blackstone before watch it's on
netflix it's like i said to you before
it's like the walking dead on cocaine
bro
first and [ __ ] [ __ ] have you ever
seen the walking dead a little bit
obviously you know the premise
no i said i've watched season one of the
walking dead
and then i got into season two
you know at that point before the show
turned
to like the civilization side of it it
was still about the zombies yeah i was
like midway through for season two and i
was like
this is going no no way yeah this is
coming i think that's not
like season five or something how long
are we gonna run from these zombies i
think they're still doing walking dead
now
yeah they are it's moved to disney plus
now
yes or so the new season is coming out
on disney blood so yeah yeah but anyway
someone black someone so black summer
before
before i dive into black summer yes i
said it's similar to walking dead by
have you ever seen a
movie called vantage point with forest
whitaker
or forest whiskers brother i can't
remember which one it is forest
whittaker
advantage okay the movie vantage point
is about
and i think an explosion happens in i
think they're in france i could be
butchering it could be frozen could be
america i don't know there's an
explosion that happens
but it track and there's like seven or
eight main characters
in this in the movie um and the vantage
point is it tracks their movement
before this explosion happens so let's
say forest whisker for example or me for
example
i'm in manchester chilling now and i'm
going to work and the explosion happens
at work
so it's tracking my day before the
explosion yeah yeah yeah once the
explosion happens it rewinds back then
it goes to you yes
and it says what i'm doing what you're
doing is okay
yeah so in the first few episodes of
black summer
it shows it shows different vantage
points of different
of the different main characters before
they all meet or
meet and see how the show pans out but
when i
say to you bro in walking dead the
zombies
aren't there aren't as lucid as you
would think they're a bit slow they're a
bit groggy
but there's bear of them that's why it's
hard these
man in black summer they
pace after you like what's that [ __ ]
thing
what's that that [ __ ] thing 28 days
later when mama's running out the [ __ ]
and running into the boat
yeah he's man face after you
sometimes it's the scariest thing but
it's also
one of the most arms house shows because
anyone can it's like game of thrones
sometimes
any one any character can get any
character i feel like i'm here for it
i feel like you're seeing this prayer oh
he's going to last the whole season
yeah yeah the way they doppy man off
with a young man off black summit is no
choice it's so good all right cool
that's something addictive
speaking of but in charge do you have
netflix on your phone yes of course
cool shall we do that thing what's that
thing bro
the blind reaction to sex life
guys what was alex episode episode 3
1940 i think that's precise bro yeah but
it's all over tik tok bro i know i know
i know i know i know oh i'm intrigued it
has to be that now cool
so let's do it at the same time yeah off
on netflix
so yeah thing is
we won't be able to post it on the team
but these men are gonna have to do it
with us
so we can say what second we're gonna go
to
and these men can follow with us sex
live episode
what three yeah
19 minutes 40 seconds are you sure
fairly certain i think we'll both know
so if you if you go down to i'm
scrolling through i'm on 19.
hang on nine
i'm gonna start on 1920 19
to give me a bit more context
hang on okay hang on oh [ __ ] welcome
all right you ready yeah three two one
go
oh
oh
[Applause]
my looked up to the ceiling
oh dear so that's what he's
looking at is that his real thing
fam i don't have the answers to that
question you know what's mad
mother
i've watched because because sex life
was just all over the gap yeah and then
i kept seeing number one in the uk today
i was like let me actually try and watch
the show yeah i'll watch two minutes of
the first episode i was like i'm
blocking this off
it's not for me it's just [ __ ] i can
tell the show is [ __ ] but i read the
premise
okay and the premise i'm pretty sure
it's a married woman who starts [ __ ]
her ex-boyfriend
i think okay and the ex-boyfriend is my
man that was just in the shower
and the husband is the maya man that
just went to look so i reckon he's
intentionally gone in there to see what
my man's saying
oh my my man is banging his wife he
wants to know what's really packing
now he knows that's why he looked up
no homo that can't be real that can't be
real
packing because my man's the actor in it
what do you mean i'm sure he's the actor
from um magic mike
i don't really pay attention to his face
i'm pretty sure it's the actor from
magic mind not obviously not challenging
but the other guy the young guy i can't
really remember all right
i can't remember i'm not gonna lie to
you um what else is he in
oh he was in some like superhero type
movie like at school like
number two or number seven or some [ __ ]
like that i
think i know which movie you're talking
about yeah they only made one of it when
you look like they could have made two
and three yeah
yeah exactly he's in that as well yeah
exactly for the life of me what it's
called yeah yeah
um but yeah you said you had a uh
i'm gonna do one's gonna go before we do
and i'm gonna oh yeah okay all right
let's do it one's gonna go
i'm sorry i've got really good that
might be but i'm gonna do one's gonna go
first cool
also okay guys i feel like my one's
gotta go something too easy for james
so what i've done is instead of four
i've dropped it down to three
okay so there's more of a decision
making process
okay yes okay i like that let's go
and this one is completely random so
none of them correlate in terms of like
the different categories
yeah yeah the first one theme parks
video games arcades
one's gotta go theme parks video games
arcades
speaking of let me just pause yeah again
did everyone see what i posted on my
story the other week did everyone
actually see
it i don't if i don't i think i know
what you're talking about i don't know
if i saw you post my
i'm pretty sure i know what you're
talking about is it the arcade thing
that was nearly falling over
no fam okay no what did you post i got
the highest high score on a basketball
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i can't
remember what it was but yes i did i was
like a week and a half going up
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
the high school was 250 that's what i
said at
i never got anywhere near that mi in
life bro i got like 347 bro
i can't be stopped bro i was talking
smack on my story
and i saw there was one person i knew i
was gonna pile up
and it was jacob he thinks he's all
golden on that
he thinks he's the golden boy on that
bro
i'm steph curry when it comes to the
arcade basketball i can't be stopped
yeah bro
when i posted that i was talking the
most smack once it got to the last one
he messaged me so send me your location
man was personally offended
i said big money always what's the
winner you literally
don't want anything part of this you
don't want it
you don't want this bro that's hilarious
you'll get grip stop but did you do
and do you know what the reference i was
talking about oh yeah
okay it fell off no no in the theme park
there was a ride it's one of those rides
that just keep going like you're in a
long um what's the word the seats are
raised this way and you're strapped in
but the ride goes like this yes i know
what ones you talk about
but the right the right the momentum of
the the ride was going so
quick it was toppling the whole thing so
it kept on rocking like this way oh [ __ ]
this way
and it happened happened like the last
week or so in america
it fell over it didn't fall off the way
kept on oh hell no
everyone was screaming james locked
their team off and after the first rock
press okay
i don't care but obviously they do that
though
obviously they press stop in it and it
slows down and it stops that's how
people get off the ride
so just stop here and it will go
and even if it's up here just give it a
quick
until it comes around surely man wasn't
paying attention
that's what was happening man was
chirping breaming bro
if i'm on a ride and the thing buckles
like that oh
i'll pass out the compensation i'm
looking i'm assuming
someone i'm suing someone
[ __ ] that bro and you think if it goes
around once um does that rock thing and
you let me go around the second time oh
my lo
i'm on my phone to my lawyer while i'm
on the thing
we're getting that friends money i think
we're getting
a million years we're getting that
schwimmer money oh you best believe it
bro
that's just that leblanc money but yeah
okay theme parks video games i'm sorry i
forgot
theme parks video games and arcades yeah
[ __ ] that's a tough one because it's
only three
[ __ ] i'm gonna say even though i love
them and obviously i'm splash city
arcades can go okay there's just there's
once you get to our age you realize
there's only so many archaic
novelty wears off yeah there's only so
many up when i get to arcade i just want
to play basketball okay i don't want to
do anything else
maybe a little bit of that thing ice
hockey what's that yeah
the air hockey that's right air healthy
yeah elky
hey hockey basketball maybe a quick
resident evil
true they always have resident evil 405
always always bro
yeah uh maybe a punch bag if i'm feeling
boujee
yeah i love about you yeah i love a
punch i know you do gee
you in harsh used to go off on a punch
bag that means snap your wrists
i nearly said i sprained my wrist in
tenerife one of my boys in 2017 when i
first moved to manning uh
[ __ ] on my
two shots later
fingers toes or your lips
toes why because i can't be walking
around with no
lips fam i can't be rocking around with
no
lips you'll be able to walk if you have
noticed bro
at least if i'm on a wheelchair like i
can still live
no lips and no fingers
what am i supposed to do with no fingers
i have to have fingers that have to have
lips yeah i hate that i have to have
lips but i need them bro
yeah then it makes me think some people
don't have lips
but everyone they put the lipstick on
you just barely see it
but um yeah i need my lips and i need my
fingers bro
toes i hate to see him go i literally
hate to see him going right
but if it's a wheelchair thing yeah
if it's a wheelchair i will survive yeah
at least i've still got my sense of
humor man if i lose my fingers
i've got nothing left
i've got nothing left that is hilarious
all right better next one
sex money
friends oh sex can go yeah
okay that was an easy choice yeah bro
for the rest of your life yeah man you
think i'm going without friends for the
rest of my life
have you lost your mind i'm not saying
you are bro
i made it 16 17 years about sex i can
make it the rest of the way
no friends and no pee
to be fair i've made it this far about
pete
i made it this far oh that's hilarious
all right
okay masturbation one's gotta go what
yeah of course
this is what we're playing i thought we
played a different game
i said what's going on kissing or
or oh okay uh i say all right all
can go
and i had to think you can't eat [ __ ]
bro
it's oral oh man
what is it kissing what masturbation oh
my smash is staying so oral can go it's
gonna have to go
it literally is gonna have to go that's
hilarious
that is hilarious all right last but not
least
all might okay minotaur
yeah netero
just for reference for those of for guys
that don't know all might
he's one of the main characters in um my
hero academia
he's looking here is that guy there he's
literally that guy right there
um minotau is um naruto's dad in
naruto and netaro is old man that's
where he's the chairman of hunter
rickshaw as well right
sucks but i'm actually gonna say
netarokan guy why did you think i was
going to say military i didn't know you
were going to say
oh okay netaro can go because i just
i can't respect a guy who got smacked up
by an ant
miriam was strong bro oh i know he was
strong bro
but they took us through netaro's whole
life story
life story from when he ain't [ __ ]
all the way to he when he became the man
he is
to show us this grand amazing [ __ ]
that made him the chairman of the
hunters association
for five minutes later he's done but he
the things he gave he literally gave his
life for the course i know he did
but
there are plenty of characters in
general that i would get rid of before
netaware don't get me wrong
but minotaur me and mineto have a
connection because when
that game came out naruto
what was it called i don't know i know
naruto sutton number two
me a minute when i was playing online
back when we lived in grafton
yeah bro i was smacking man up in a
global level
global level i was running man down
no one in the yard was respecting the
the [ __ ] that i was doing
with minotaur bro yeah i weren't losing
family
i was climbing ranks in the global
leagues yeah climbing ranks bro i didn't
sleep for days
wow i was in that living room playing
day in day out but i was on it me and
minato were like this
we were not losing bro there's a couple
man that came strong with dadara i'm not
gonna lie
man wow i knew it was long as they if
they dropped her up i knew it was long
and if they dropped um so sorry
i can't remember with his puppets yeah
the hunchback looking
uh bro if he came in with cesaro dead or
i knew i was in for a fight he was
annoying
if they came with naruto or [ __ ]
kakashi
it's a rafi yeah yeah yeah i said rap
but child of beethoven they used to come
in thinking they could mix up now it's a
rap view
it's long so long but um yeah if they
came with
um so sorry or deidre i knew i was in
for a fight
but bro me and minotaur weren't losing
so just from that
i can't lock him off he can't go right
okay um
and then they change the game in number
three where they limit the amount of
substitution juices you could do
you could only do three substitution
juices and then it would have to
recharge
[ __ ] my whole game plan up i was missed
the substitution yeah
so as soon as that happened i'm not
playing this game anymore fair enough
bro
um so neto can go and but who's the
first one in there as well
all right oh my yeah almost just a guy
in it
he gave it all for the course
to the point where only his arm was wham
and he still did the thing but literally
he sold in metro and gave it all for the
course
i know he did but probably because i
hated the chimera arc
so much bro i hated that entire it went
on for like
50 [ __ ] episodes man just to get to
the point that we're at
from when these men were finding guns
and just shooting villagers
i was like this shows this show i'm
losing interest in the show
and from when like i forgot about that
yeah i was like this is terrible now
and then when from when my man who was
like the captains like catching feelings
for humans and like
starting to save them and then you had
um the other ants the lieutenants or
whatever would go off and they'll find
their own kingdom because they want to
be
[ __ ] kings and i was just like this
is so dumb
like this is so dumb and that just it
went on for so long bro and then we
finally get to like the mero ml
arc and stuff like that and you know all
right let's go let's go and
granted network part of a fight it was a
scrap don't get me wrong
yeah a hundred pound thing he's his his
his men was live
but it's just like meru's been alive six
hours
he was born two days ago yeah yeah and
he's smacking at the chairman
and it's just like we haven't seen him
fight anyone else he was just lopping
people's heads off with his tail
and he looked exactly like cell which
frustrated me
looks exactly like cell and chopped
people's heads off just like cell does
with his tail does [ __ ] with his tail
bro anyway
he's been he was born two days ago what
he does
is is play shogi with this blind
person yeah yeah yeah and then um he
hasn't fought
anyone of worth and then all of a sudden
the [ __ ] chairman
squares up and loses this is marilyn's
first
fight ever and he beats the most
powerful character in the entire show
valid point
i'll accept that i'm saying all right
and it's not netaro's fault bro but it's
just like
what are we even doing here what are we
even doing here
we could have bought someone else to
scrap my man someone maybe
he could have killed [ __ ] um
kilowatt's granddad bro
yeah man maybe he could exactly
he's arms bro his arms
so just bring him in he's a side
character yeah why are you gonna bring
in the chairman the top dawn yeah
in the whole show there's no one above
him it would have been so much better if
let's say he did kill the grandfather
right and obviously the grandfather and
nettle were like are chatting because
we're also boys at the same time yeah
the left wing's got like got a reason to
go oh
that would have happened thank you bro
that would have panned
ah that would have happened killer was
dead as well with [ __ ] ah yeah so now
we've got two beefs
netrosvex and killer was dad's vex
killer was vexed as well
everyone's vex i would have been foaming
at the dick to watch that bro
i would have been firming at the dick to
watch that yeah yeah yeah but they
killed off the top
dawn i hear you now i hear you
okay
yeah this might go down as the longest
episode ever
maybe no it won't no to be fair bella's
episode
okay one four five was a very long
episode so that's
episode 63 there you go
i think it was [ __ ] out if it was 63
that was
37 episodes ago yep
wow that was 37 weeks ago guys wow
right am i the hey guys
love the pod i am eight i am an 18 year
old boy from sweden
okay so the story is a few months ago i
had a girlfriend that had been dating
for two years
and everything was great but towards the
end i felt like our sex and relationship
as a whole was getting a bit boring
at the end of our relationship the sex
was great and what sorry at the start of
our relationship the sex was great
and we're going out and like rabbits but
eventually everything fell off
i felt like i wanted to explore other
things so i ended it
but i still had so i still had her
around for sex sometimes
two weeks after we broke up i met with a
girl
that had been on me even when i wasn't
single and we had sex
eventually my ex found out and went
crazy because she felt like i lied to
her
am i the answer for [ __ ] another girl
while still having my ex run for some
sloppy top
do you want me to give you a quick cap
um so
young guy girlfriend broke up
but still wanted the nut but did he
broke up because his ex wasn't banging
anymore
okay so broke up because of the sex then
continued to have the sex but got rid of
everything else
um then
continued to be bored of the sex so we
started talking to another thing
and bang the levitating and then the
thing that
was liking him whilst he was in a
relationship with this other two and the
other chick knew
or he didn't say the others you knew
that she liked it yeah you didn't say
okay cool you didn't say it
so then he's banged himself off the ex
found out that the answer cool so banned
another girl while he's still sleeping
with their ex
um yeah to me
in that circumstance 100 is an arsenal
100 percent as an [ __ ] he said the
sex
really isn't it so i want to end this
relationship
but i still want to use you for the
thing that i'm
dumping you for so that i have
leeway to [ __ ] someone else so
i'm dropping my connection with you so i
can have something that's purely
physical with you
even though the physical thing is the
reason i don't want to have anything
romantic with you
so i want to keep the physical so i can
have all what so i can literally
use you for what i want until the
opportunity
arises that i can have something that's
better than you and i will
go and do that but don't worry i'm still
probably going to try and come [ __ ] you
again
100 [ __ ] bro i ready and i was like
oh my god but the thing that made me go
oh my god well there were two things
that made me go oh my god
he said i have an 18 year old boy from
sweden come he said i've been dating
this girl
for two years so he started dating when
he was 16.
yeah but towards the end of relation man
said
everything was great but towards the end
i felt like our sex and the relationship
got a bit
boring you're 18 yeah you
you've just started you don't know what
sex is like
you don't know what's imagining got
boring at 18 and you want to look for
more
what are we talking about here what what
is he trying to
explore bro this is what i said you
remember a few months ago i said do you
think porn is ruminous
sex yes for people yes this is a prime
example
he's out thinking bro i'm looking for
bubbles he's looking for bubbles galore
and anal girl
yeah he wants yeah
enough isn't willing to give up yeah
she's she's just started this game she's
17
big man you find out you started [ __ ]
she was 15
now she's a young ting man yeah her b
let her grow you
bro you're coming in with this toxic
masculinity [ __ ] toxic masculine at 18
big man
yeah man man said he's 18 people for two
years and he wants
more because i don't even know what
what kind of sex i was having bro when i
was 18 i was horny as
hell bro i was happy for missionary
every day
i was gasped for any skin on skin bro i
didn't care about this morning
i didn't care you're letting me inside
you bro there was no such thing as more
i was here for everything and porn is
ruining the whole
thing it actually is porn is [ __ ] up
the whole thing bro oh my
god for these youngans who don't know
what it is just don't know what the real
thing is
bro they're expecting madness that they
can't even appreciate the basics bro
you gotta live in the fundamentals for
years
at the start of our relationship the sex
was great were acting like rabbits but
eventually it fell off
wow mad
yes sorry sorry bro you are the [ __ ]
you are the [ __ ] it's such a
no-brainer it's ridiculous
but there's no
there's no um what's the word there's no
denying you why they are solved
but i can also as an eight-year-old
horny little guy
i can understand especially in this day
and age where we've got the social media
we've got access to pawn so easily like
back in when we were 18 porn wasn't
readily available like that that wasn't
the dial up was
long yeah knew you were on the internet
where you couldn't [ __ ] use the
[ __ ]
house landline you know yeah and the new
ones in the internet so it's harder to
put myself in an 18 year old mind of
nowadays because
the accessibility of so much porn and
like the diverseness and
all this stuff that's happening now is
so readily available
so i can understand why he may seem they
have wanted more you know and it's also
[ __ ] up
her self-esteem and her like
her view on sex yeah she now has to she
now feels like she has to
put out a lot more than she's willing to
give yeah man just to keep my
interest interested interested to stay
in a relationship that's psychologically
[ __ ] her up
because now she's thinking the only way
to keep a man is anal
the only way to keep a man is bubbles
galore
not this regular regular penetration of
the vagina
bro it's all sorts three something
anal butt plugs bro a lot for a teenager
choking on talk that's a lot for a
teenager bro she ready for that
[ __ ] it's ready for that big man if 18
year old me if one of if a girl sees
something that's [ __ ] sticking my
[ __ ] bible
i don't know if i'm ready for that what
do you mean
i don't know if i didn't i don't even
know if i knew about anal back then oh
it didn't even cross my mind gas to
slide in the vagina
what's that
that's three levels up three levels up
i've not even had a bombay roll yet
yeah i'm talking about anal yeah yeah
yeah you might want a different kind of
fish
yeah bro show me a titty a real titty
when i was 18. oh i lost my mind i would
have lost
my marbles man's talking about i'm bored
bored bored wow
what a way to what thing to say about
your woman
you know yeah this is boring now i'm i
don't actually wanna
the sex has fallen off i don't wanna be
with you anymore
i actually don't think i wanna be with
you anymore wow
and she said right you wanna break up
with me yeah yeah
but i'm still trying to not when you
watch this episode i want to ask you
how do you think that made her feel i
want you to answer me honestly as well
because
obviously when you when you guys send us
the admire the [ __ ] yes you guys are
thinking from your point of view and
thinking up front about
how this affects you but how do you
think it affected her
because i'm assuming she's in and around
your age bracket as you said you were
dating for or in a relationship for two
years so i'm assuming from 16 to 18 you
were with this girl
and she was if i'm assuming around the
same age 15 17 16 18.
this is again my assumption her first
true experience of sex
relationship i wanted that malarkey you
know yeah
and you're saying you're literally
telling her you may not talk about
you're literally saying to her
big man i'm bored of what we're doing
right now
i need something more an inside
exclusive i need something wilder
i want to try new [ __ ] you're not down
for it so i'm out
bro that would have [ __ ] with her mind
she now has to think that the only way i
can keep a man
is to be the nastiest slag and that
that's probably how she's going to be
asleep
yeah and now she wanted to keep her man
now now exactly she won't be able to
keep her man
yeah bro that's tough what a downer
anyway wow thanks guys let's take a shot
yeah to finish let's take a shot to
finish all right man let's pull this
back we can't end on that
you can't end up you man um like we said
at the beginning of the episode
we ride for you you ride for us we [ __ ]
with you you [ __ ] with us
we're so happy and so elated that we
could even
be in this position to have 100 episodes
um
we want to thank you thank the viewers
thank you for those that watch
thank you for those i listen thank you
for those of you both thank you
all you guys are sliding on dms thank
you even though we don't get back to all
of you at the same time or
in a in a quick fashion we apologize but
still thank you for sending us the dms
thank you for being patient with us
thank you for all the glitches thank you
for
thank you for 100 man and here's the two
well done good speech g
that's huge crazy okay this one's gonna
send me over the edge i already know it
happy hundred bro happy
[Music]
smg out peace guys